[Music]
gorgeous as always
you know I have been so happy for you
your career has just gone so beautifully
you've had so much success and I think
back to I think I met you for the first
time ten years ago when you were on that
70s show yeah and I was talking to you
and you were a kid at the time and you
were talking about how much you loved
prank calling people on a telephone yeah
and now you're the mila kunis that is in
movies you're a huge star is that person
is that still part of you you still like
to prank call yeah it's just a little
harder to do it now because my voice is
so recognizable and I'm not skilled
enough to change so it is what it is so
sometimes you'll prank call people and
they'll say is this Mila Kunis from
Black Swan I used to play play video
games and I had a hard time being on the
voice systems like Ventrilo and stuff
because my voice started becoming
recognizable and you have a very
distinct voice yeah what about like the
technology change too when you call
people you know yeah people don't pick
up private calls everyone's like
self-indulgent they think they're too
good to pick up a black call right so I
can't prank call people anymore
it's really uncomfortable but I do try
it was the worst thing that ever
happened is when caller ID I have to ask
you something you're an extraordinarily
attractive woman yet I read recently you
said the following that you feel that
you are a gay man trapped in a woman's
body
this intrigued me I feel like a gay
woman trapped in a woman's body I don't
even know how that makes sense but no
explain that to me and what do you mean
by that without being like you know full
of stereotypes um I mean it is what it
is I feel like a good sometimes in a
woman's body I love men I love
everything about men and I sometimes
love getting dressed up and looking like
a fabulous drag queen and going about
town in West Hollywood and right and
having a you know a gale time right do
you have
oh now we can bond I got your back
girlfriend
you let you have a roommate you ever
who's who's gay
I do yeah and and so does he understand
what you're talking about
yes yeah he gets it like you you two get
together and he understands you know he
loves Madonna a little bit more than I
do but other than that she's a serial
killer she insists on destroying all DNA
before she will leave her dress I don't
know about that really yes well then it
must be true yeah we're in the news what
I don't know no it was apparently a news
story this is something that she likes
to have done like she disinfects I mean
how do you really do I may have just out
of curiosity I know how it's done
whenever I go anywhere I have the place
swept with a better question is is what
is she spraying DNA all over the place
it's never been an issue for me you know
really well
it was the circus yeah